hello welcome to this video it's an
announcement video yes I will do a live
stream on Wednesday September 16th and
this will not be on the channel that I'm
usually streaming on on Mondays the ICC
cello but on my own twitch channel which
is underused admittedly and what is it
yeah there's a tournament on chess calm
and it's called the streamers challenge
which is basically a tournament where
everybody who plays is um yeah he needs
an everybody needs to stream who's
playing yeah so we have people on
streaming like Gil Maya Jean Ludwig
hammer Maxim blue Eric handsome yeah
they're also the YouTube guys like John
Bartholomew like me yeah they're split
stream there's hutch as Denny wrench or
some other guys so we'll be a nice nice
event seven rounds of blitz chess three
minute to second increment is actually
for money yeah three thousand dollar
cash but you see it's a strong event I'm
not really in it for the money but for
having some fun yeah so make sure to
join me I'll be kicking off with my
stream a little bit before that the
actual start of the event is some as you
see here 1 p.m. pacific daytime for PM
eastern day time which makes it ten in
the evening and central europe and i'll
be on a little bit earlier probably one
hour before that so on on nine in the
evening in Central Europe in Germany for
example or France or Italy and this
would make it 3 p.m. vs in daytime or
noon pacific date i'm just i'm a bit on
earlier on then the son of the event to
just get used to the chess.com interface
I really never play there so I have to
be have to have some kind of adjustment
yeah make sure to be on the right
channel this is the right channel
twitch.tv dan
explained it is chess explained without
the e yeah fun fact I tried to register
that but it has s-e-x in it then and
people i mean i know people what witches
witches somehow thinking that this is
kind of inappropriate so i had to ditch
the e them yeah make sure to to get that
right i also have it in them and then
the company text box here yeah make sure
to join me at yes i said 9pm central
europe in time thanks for watching this
video and we'll see each other in a
couple of hours thanks